this morning the U.S is holding a
suspected terrorist it sought for 34
years ever since a bomb brought down Pan
Am flight 103 over Lockerbie Scotland
killing 270 people among them 190
Americans the accused Bob maker Abu
agila Mohammed Masood at one point had
been held in Libya senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is at
the justice department this morning
following all of this Catherine victims
families say it felt like a dream when
they heard this news good morning
that's right Tony good morning while we
still don't know how the alleged bomb
maker came into U.S custody or why now
after 34 years for the families there is
relief and amazement
was like wow it's actually a reality
Kira weebs is the president of the
victims of Pan Am flight 103. this is
the last photo of Kara with her brother
Rick minetti one of 35 Syracuse
University students killed on the flight
he looked at the day that he was coming
home
as you know what a great day that was
going to be
and that part always gets me four days
before Christmas in 1988 the shattered
nose and cockpit bearing the name
Clipper made of the Seas symbolized
American lives lost to International
terrorism a bomb ripped through the
luggage hold an hour into the flight
from London to New York's JFK 259 lives
cut short on the flight 11 more killed
by Falling debris in Lockerbie Scotland
this heinous assault lives in infamy in
the collective memory of the American
people two years ago the justice
department announced charges against Abu
agila Muhammad Masood the alleged bomb
maker Masood is the third Libyan charged
in connection with the terrorist attack
but he would be the first to stand trial
in an American Court What mattered most
to the families having Justice play out
in the in the United States
the blast at 31 000 feet was so powerful
the crime scene spanned more than 840
square miles an international team of
investigators pieced together fragments
of the jet ultimately leading to parts
of a cassette recorder packed with
explosives I did have a lot of faith in
them that this day would come Rick
minetti's Journal was recovered from the
crash site it still inspires his sister
one of the things that really sticks is
when he talked about living life and and
how you know you should go after things
and not sit back
well the families have managed to keep
their case in front of six
administrations there is still no trial
date set from a suit we've sold CBS news
that she does plan to attend in person
deal
that's tough thank you very much
Catherine